Traduttore: Sofia Ramundo
Allora, alzino la mano
quanti di voi hanno pensato
almeno una volta nella vita di andarsene.
Non per forza dall'Italia,
anche semplicemente
dal proprio paese
o dalla propria città.
Vediamo?
Eh, appunto. (Risata)
Allora, diciamo che
nella mia pur breve
esperienza da giornalista
ho già avuto modo di raccogliere
un po' di voci
di italiani che lavorano all'estero,
per il giornale con cui collaboro,
e devo dire
che sono sempre uscite fuori
delle storie molto interessanti.
Prima di cominciare, però,
voglio farvi vedere qualche dato.
Ok, ci provo.
No, eh?
Ok.
Eccolo qua.
Allora, soltanto nel 2015
sono partire dall'Italia 107.000 persone,
di cui la maggior parte
con meno di 35 anni.
Invece dal 2006 al 2016,
il numero di italiani
che si sono trasferiti all'estero
è aumentato di quasi il 55%.
Ora, per favore,
prima di pensarci, di andar via,
ascoltatemi un attimo almeno.
Comunque,
la parte più interessante del mio lavoro
consiste nel raccogliere
le esperienze di queste persone
e di raccontarle ovviamente
nel modo più accattivante possibile,
in modo che poi il pubblico, voi tutti
le condividiate sui social,
ovviamente, ma anche e soprattutto a voce.
Vedete, io mi ritengo molto fortunata
a fare questo lavoro,
perché mi permette di ascoltare
le voci di un'intera generazione,
una generazione che è divisa
tra radici e futuro.
Una generazione che ha investito
tantissimo nei propri studi.
La maggior parte
delle persone con cui parlo
sono mie coetanee
o sono poco più grandi di me.
Eppure hanno tutti alle spalle
un grosso bagaglio di esperienze.
Sono quasi tutti laureati,
hanno fatto almeno
un Master o un Dottorato.
Insomma hanno investito
una bella parte della loro giovinezza
a coltivare una pianta,
a innaffiarla giorno dopo giorno.
Questa pianta per me è il loro talento.
E una volta che però
questa pianta è diventata un albero,
allora quell'albero
dentro casa non ci stava più.
E loro si sono chiesti:
"Qual è la direzione giusta da prendere,
ma soprattutto,
c'è una direziona giusta da prendere?"
Io a volte me li immagino
seduti alla loro scrivania,
che sia a Catania o a Trento,
con davanti un foglio bianco da riempire.
Nella colonna sinistra
i vantaggi di lasciare l'Italia,
in quella destra gli svantaggi.
Io non ci ho mai provato
però mi assicurano
che queste liste funzionano alla grande.
Comunque, nella colonna di sinistra
vedete che tra i vantaggi
di lasciare l'Italia metteranno
uno stipendio più alto,
migliori opportunità di crescita
all'interno del posto di lavoro,
e ovviamente il contratto
a tempo indeterminato.
In quella degli svantaggi
non mancheranno la pizza o la lasagna
della mamma o della nonna,
le domeniche allo stadio,
i sabati pomeriggi con gli amici,
i monumenti, che in Italia
dove cammini cammini
respiri comunque la Storia.
E a un certo punto,
a furia di compilare questa lista
si saranno detti:
beh, è ora di fare i conti.
E che alla fine abbiano vinto
i vantaggi di lasciare l'Italia.
E c'è un perché: l'estero,
ai loro occhi, ai miei,
e probabilmente anche ai vostri,
non è soltanto un'opportunità di riscatto,
è anche un'occasione, un cambiamento.
E il cambiamento devi essere tu
a inventartelo, a innescarlo.
Loro lo hanno fatto,
hanno riempito una valigia dei sogni,
qualcuno magari tra un vestito e l'altro
ci ha infilato pure
qualche pacco di pasta.
E poi, però, sono partiti.
I cervelli in fuga
li divido in tre categorie:
quelli che "con l'Italia ho chiuso",
quelli che "volevo vivere la mia vita
con lo zaino in spalla",
e infine quelli che
"io volevo molto di più".
I primi, i delusi, se ne sono andati
perché l'Italia
non gli ha dato abbastanza,
perché gli ha negato
il lavoro che volevano,
o più semplicemente
gli ha negato un lavoro.
Gli "zaino in spalla" invece
se ne sarebbero andati comunque,
troppa è la voglia di sapere
quello che c'è
oltre i confini del nostro Paese,
di conoscere altre tradizioni,
altre culture.
Infine ci sono i "voglio molto di più".
Ecco, loro se ne sono andati
pur avendo già un lavoro in Italia.
Pensate, tra loro c'è perfino
chi ha rinunciato
a un contratto a tempo indeterminato.
Uno dei primi cervelli in fuga
che ho intervistato,
un paio di anni fa,
mi ha raccontato che lui
aveva un buon lavoro a Roma,
uno stipendio, un contratto
a tempo indeterminato.
Insomma, poteva essere soddisfatto.
Ma non lo era,
non era felice della sua vita.
Così ad un certo punto si è licenziato
e ha fondato un blog in cui
insegna alle persone come creare,
come gestire il proprio sito web.
E quando ha visto
che quell'idea funzionava
si è detto "Beh, ma a me per lavorare
mi basta un computer.
Che senso ha starmene fermo in Italia?'.
Lui ovviamente
era anche uno "zaino in spalla".
Così se n'è andato in Thailandia,
una terra di cui si era innamorato
qualche anno prima,
dove con 400 euro al mese
affitti una casa davanti al mare,
e con 4 euro
fai un pasto completo al ristorante.
E insomma, provate a dargli torto.
Tra le persone che ho intervistato,
c'è anche chi se n'è andato
per esigenze lavorative,
perchè magari voleva studiare
da vicino la barriera corallina
o perché, per portare avanti
il suo progetto di ricerca
in campo scientifico,
aveva bisogno di macchinari,
di tecnologie più avanzate,
e soprattutto aveva bisogno di più fondi.
C'è chi invece se n'è andato all'estero
per realizzare i sogni di bambino,
che fosse quello di diventare
un attore o uno scienziato.
Altri invece se ne sono andati
per coltivare i sogni della maturità.
Prendere il mutuo, sposarsi,
avere un lavoro stabile.
Insomma, ognuno di loro
aveva una motivazione particolare,
ma sono tutte persone
che rendono grande ogni giorno
il nostro Paese all'estero.
Che hanno messo in circolo il loro talento
e che ogni giorno fanno dei sacrifici
per andare avanti.
Ecco, queste sono solo alcune delle città
in cui vivono le persone
che ho intervistato in questi ultimi anni.
Tra loro c'è chi è riuscito
a fare la scalata
e da lavapiatti, a Londra,
è diventato un importante
rappresentante di case d'asta.
E chi a 40 anni mi ha detto:
"Napoli è la città più bella del mondo
ma io me ne sono andato
perché dovevo fare il salto di qualità".
Persone che se ne sono andate quindi
per ritrovare la gioia di lavorare,
che non si sono accontentate,
in quel momento,
di quello che l'Italia
poteva offrire loro.
Ho parlato, in questi anni,
con ingegneri informatici
partiti in massa per l'Irlanda.
E con ristoratori, italiani ovvviamente,
giovani e meno giovani,
che hanno fatto fortuna a New York,
grazie al loro talento
e alla nostra cucina.
Ho parlato con medici che in Svizzera
hanno trovato
la loro personalissima America,
a due passi dall'Italia.
Perché lì gli stipendi
sono 3 volte più alti
e le strutture ospedaliere
funzionano benissimo.
C'è chi mi ha detto, invece,
che se n'è andato dall'Italia
perché gli italiani
sono sempre tutti arrabbiati.
E che invece in Australia hanno tutti
il sorriso stampato sulle labbra.
Mi hanno detto poi che Londra
è competitiva, è vero,
che però lì la tassazione
è più conveniente,
e già a 26 anni puoi avviare
un'azienda da solo.
E mi hanno detto poi che in California,
anche se non conosci il Diritto americano,
ci sono persone,
ci sono avvocati che ti dicono:
"Se tu hai voglia di imparare,
vieni qua, la porta è aperta".
Infine ho parlato, proprio da poco,
con un ingegnere,
un ingegnere aerospaziale,
nato e cresciuto a Caivano,
uno dei paesi che fanno parte
della terra dei fuochi.
Lui adesso vive e lavora a Londra
e segue un'importante missione scientifica
in collaborazione con l'ESA e con la NASA.
E quando gli ho chiesto:
"Quanto coraggio ci è voluto
a lasciare casa tua
e a trasferirti da un'altra parte?",
lui mi ha detto:
"No, il coraggio non ce l'ho avuto io,
che me ne sono andato,
il coraggio ce l'hanno
quelli che sono rimasti,
e che lottano ogni giorno
per rendere migliore la mia terra".
(Applausi)
C'è una parola che ricorre spesso
nelle nostre interviste,
ed è "responsabilizzazione".
Ecco, tutte le persone
che riescono a fare carriera all'estero,
spesso riescono anche
a ritagliarsi un ruolo importante.
Un ingegnere, ad esempio,
con cui ho parlato poco tempo fa,
che lavora in Scozia,
gestisce già, a 31 anni,
un proprio team internazionale
con 8 persone che vengono
da tutto il mondo.
Lo stesso discorso mi aveva fatto
una docente universitaria
che segue, insomma che si occupa
di ricerca sul campo,
e anche lei ormai vive e lavora
negli Stati Uniti da 10 anni
e gestisce da sola
un team importante, di persone.
Ecco, lei anche mi ha detto
che negli Stati Uniti
se lavori sodo, puoi arrivare ovunque,
perché lì è soltanto il merito che conta,
questa è la cosa più importante.
Insomma, ci sono tutte persone
che in un modo o nell'altro
sono riuscite ad affermarsi
nel loro Paese.
Tra loro il vero problema però,
ed è quello su cui io
mi interrogo più spesso
alla fine di queste interviste,
non è che se ne siano andati, no?
Come hanno detto alcune persone
che hanno parlato prima di me.
Il problema è che queste persone poi
non tornano quasi mai in Italia.
E a molti di loro piacerebbe farlo.
Io alla fine delle nostre interviste
glielo chiedo sempre:
"Ma tu in futuro dove ti vedi?
In Italia o in Europa?
eh, scusate... all'estero o in Italia?"
E loro mi rispondono:
"È ovvio che mi piacerebbe tornare,
perché l'Italia è un Paese meraviglioso".
Ma c'è una clausola che aggiungono tutti,
senza distinzione di sesso, età, genere.
Dicono "Tornerei certo, ma soltanto
alle mie condizioni".
Ed è giusto che sia così, perché una volta
che hai imparato ad alzare l'asticella,
poi non ha senso
ricalibrarla verso il basso.
Allora mi chiedo e vi chiedo,
è davvero così mediocre
questa Italia che fa tanto,
tantissimo per la formazione
di questi giovani,
e poi se li lascia scappare via.
Io non ho,
ovviamente non posso essere io
a dare una risposta
a un interrogativo così importante,
però mi piace pensare che no,
non sia poi così mediocre,
che se la stia solo passando
un po' male ultimamente,
e che d'altronde poi la migrazione
fa parte dell'uomo, fin dall'antichità.
E quindi non è giusto
rifilarle tutta la colpa.
Tra l'altro,
tutte le persone con cui parlo,
mi hanno confermato
che la preparazione scolastica
e universitaria che hanno ricevuto
in Italia è ineguagliabile,
e che bisogna proprio vivere
all'estero per capirlo.
Ci sarà pure un motivo poi
se la Germania, gli Stati Uniti,
la gettonatissima Australia,
fanno a gara per contendersi
i nostri cervelli in fuga.
Ecco, poco tempo fa,
proprio qualche giorno fa,
ho fatto un'esperienza nuova.
Invece di parlare con un cervello in fuga,
ho parlato con la mamma
di un cervello in fuga,
che ha avuto la brillante idea
di aprire un blog
in cui raccoglie le storie
di tutti i genitori che come lei
vivono lontani dai figli.
E io prima di chiamarla,
pensavo, mi immaginavo,
un battaglione di madri e padri
arrabbiati con l'Italia,
per non aver fornito ai loro figli
il pretesto per restare.
E invece mi sbagliavo.
Lei stessa mi ha confermato
che sia lei che tutte le persone
con cui ha parlato in questi anni,
sono più che orgogliose
del percorso che hanno fatto i figli,
e sono felici del fatto che i figli
abbiano potuto fare una...
abbiano potuto prendere
una decisione così importante.
Tra l'altro questa
è stata un'occasione anche in più
per i loro genitori,
un'occasione in più per viaggiare,
per conoscere una nuova lingua,
per conoscere persone nuove.
Insomma, la verità,
quello che l'estero offre in più
rispetto all'Italia
è che all'estero si può provare
e vivere, e soprattutto provare.
All'estero hai uno spazio vitale
per cadere e rialzarti in piedi,
c'è maggiore fiducia
nelle capacità del singolo.
Insomma, ti senti padrone del tuo destino.
E a 20, 30, 40, 60 anni forse
è questo quello che vogliamo tutti.
Essere padroni del nostro destino.
Invece il sentiero comune
ci porta a pensare che in Italia
hai una cartuccia da sparare,
e se quella non va a segno,
ti tocca ripartire da zero.
Io però ho parlato anche
con quelle persone
che sono ritornate in Italia.
E quando poi mi vado a leggere
i commenti sotto agli articoli
ci rimango sempre un po' male
perché tutti scrivono:
"Ma che è tornato a fare,
qui non c'è lavoro per nessuno".
E invece loro, fieri, spiegano
che era arrivato il momento
di tornare e di rimettere
al servizio dell'Italia il loro talento
e i loro studi e anche, ovviamente,
la loro esperienza all'estero.
Una ragazza in particolar modo
mi è rimasta impressa
perché subito dopo la laurea
in ingegneria era andata in Germania
e le avevano offerto un contratto
da global manager
in cui lei gestiva da sola un fatturato
di 50 milioni di dollari l'anno.
Arrivata alla soglia dei 30 anni però,
dopo questa carriera importantissima,
si è detta, ma io dove metto le radici,
in Italia o in Germania,
che è vero, la Germania è efficientissima,
ci sono delle ottime politiche familiari,
ma io qui mi sento privata
della mia identità culturale.
Così ha buttato il cuore
oltre l'ostacolo e ha detto:
"Io ci provo, ci provo
a tornare in Italia".
Ha cominciato a mandare curriculum,
a fare colloqui via Skype,
e le cose non andavano proprio
come pensava,
perché tutte le aziende le dicevano:
"Mi spiace, ma tu sei troppo qualificata,
qui dovresti ripartire da zero".
Insomma, il fatto che lei avesse fatto
un'esperienza così significativa
all'estero,
non era visto come un valore aggiunto,
ma anzi come un fattore di rischio,
e vi assicuro che non è stata l'unica
ad avermene parlato.
Lei però si è rimboccata
le maniche comunque,
in Italia c'è tornata,
si è aperta una start up con tre amici,
che punta a far riscoprire
l'eccellenza alimentare
in spazi per l'Italia,
dimostrando che a volte
anche in Italia, il lavoro
uno se lo può inventare,
giorno dopo giorno.
Generalmente, le persone
con cui parlo, sono persone felici,
perché sono persone che hanno fatto
una scelta di vita importante
e quindi sono più consapevoli
dei loro limiti e delle loro capacità.
Sono persone
che hanno fatto una scelta, dicevo,
e non serve aver studiato
economica politica
per sapere che ogni scelta
comporta una rinuncia.
Ecco, io quando parlo con loro,
non posso fare a meno di chiedermi
tutto quel...
non posso fare a meno di pensare
a tutto quello a cui hanno rinunciato.
E che loro ovviamente mi elencano
nel corso delle nostre interviste:
la famiglia mettono sempre al primo posto,
il cibo, il clima,
soprattutto per quelli che vivono
in Irlanda o in Germania,
e poi il loro mare, le loro montagne,
a seconda di dove sono nati.
Perché sì, è vero che cambiare vita
a 25 anni non è poi così difficile,
che cosa sarà mai,
però forse non è così uno scherzo.
E quando finisco queste interviste
mi chiedo sempre,
ma io ce l'avrei quel coraggio,
il coraggio di lasciare
la mia famiglia, i miei affetti,
il cibo, il clima, anche se quelli...
il mare,
anche se quello del litorale romano
non è un granché,
è pur sempre mare.
Insomma, come si fa un giorno
a decidere di mollare tutto
e ricominciare da zero.
Poi ho capito, ho capito
che l'unico segreto per farlo
è la leggerezza.
Per questo per salutarvi,
volevo proiettare questa frase
di Italo Calvino:
"Prendete la vita con leggerezza,
ché leggerezza non è superficialità,
ma planare sulle cose dall'alto,
non avere macigni sul cuore".
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)